[Music]
hello how are we doing excellent very
good I am thrilled to be here and I'm
thrilled to be talking about the topic
of how to make our communication
memorable so today is all about specific
tips and tricks that you can use so that
you can help yourself remember what
you're trying to say and to help your
audience remember well I like
communicating I love hearing you
communicate as well so today is going to
be participative and I invite you to
participate as much or as little as you
like so let's go ahead and get started
and you'll see by some of the imagery
that I'm using I'm trying to keep a very
serious subject playful so when I ask my
students or the people I coach what
worries you the most what concerns you
the most I hear two things all the time
I'm afraid I'm not gonna remember what I
need to say followed immediately by I'm
afraid my audience is gonna remember
what I say so today is all about trying
to give those tools that we can use to
make sure that our communication is
memorable and we'll start by looking at
how we can help ourselves remember our
content and then we'll move forward and
we'll talk about how to make sure that
your content is memorable and we'll
start by talking about presentation
hygiene to me presentation hygiene is
about what you do to prepare for your
communication not the actual practice
which we will talk about but
specifically what you do in your life to
get yourself ready
so to begin one of the most important
things we can do is make sure that we
eat well I coached an individual who
kept getting promoted in his
organization and he noticed that as he
got promoted he got more nervous and
more forgetful when he gave
presentations and ran meetings and I
asked him why do you think that is and
he had no idea and I said walk me
through your day and what we learned was
as he kept getting promoted his diet got
worse and worse
he was drinking more caffeine he was
eating more fast food and he couldn't
remember well so by looking into some
nutritional advice by eating more
healthy
he actually regained his confidence and
his memory so preparing for a
presentation or a important meeting like
you would prepare for some kind of
athletic event is exactly what you
should do make sure that you treat your
diet well and that you focus on elements
like what you eat and when you eat
certain foods to make sure you're
prepared quick bit of advice caffeine
while preparing your communication but
not before you deliver your
communication in addition to eating we
also have to make sure that we exercise
we have to make sure that our body is
warmed up and it works very well to
reduce stress that we have so instead of
spending a whole night cramming for that
big meeting or that big presentation
it's far better to do a little exercise
to breathe deeply and get a good night's
sleep sleep is critical to memory
formation and to making sure you have
the energy you need to communicate
effectively so simple hygiene what you
eat the exercise you do the sleep you
get can really help now we live in a
valley of Technology so part of our
hygiene in preparation needs to focus on
technology there are myriad of apps and
tools that you can use to help yourself
become a better more effective
communicator I'm going to list several
here these are tools that range from
helping you reduce the number of
disfluencies you have those are the UM
zazz likes and I means all the way
through tools that help you with your
vocal intensity in your flow one of
these tools actually allows you to dawn
VR goggles and see an imaginary audience
an audience you can determine if it's
friendly or hostile big or small you can
even see your slide deck behind you in a
virtual world leverage tools
to help you with your preparation this
is the first step to being an effective
memorable communicator next we actually
have to think about the messages that we
communicate and I believe all effective
communication all high-stakes
communication must start with a goal and
to me a goal has three key components
it's about information emotion and
action at the end of your meeting at the
end of your presentation at the end of
your email what do you want your
audience to know how do you want them to
feel and what do you want them to do you
should be able to articulate your goal
clearly before you create your content
my goal for us today is simple I'd like
for each and every one of you to leave
here with some tools and tactics you can
use to be more memorable I want you to
feel confident and dare I say excited to
try these tools and ultimately I'd love
for you to use them each of you needs to
think about what is your goal for your
upcoming high-stakes communication and
by the way having a goal not only helps
you focus what you say it also helps you
assess the success of your communication
in the work I do with my students here
and the consulting I do around the world
I often ask people how do you know if
your communication was successful and
the most frequent answer I get is I got
through it survival becomes the success
criteria and that's not where we want to
be if you have a goal you can actually
assess were you successful do the people
know what I wanted them to know are they
feeling the way I want them to feel and
ultimately are they doing what I wanted
so having a goal helps you not only hone
your message it helps you assess its
success so once we have that goal we
then need to think about how do we best
communicate our message
and I am a huge proponent of structure
structure is critical to success in
communication structure helps us in two
ways first it helps us to set our
audiences expectations and second it
helps our audience to remember I learned
this first rule very early in my life
when I was an undergraduate here at
Stanford I was a tour guide they trained
me for 12 weeks a full academic quarter
to be a tour guide to this day I can
still walk backwards in a straight line
what do you think was the most important
thing they taught us during that full
quarter in terms of being a good tour
guide here what do you think shout out
some of the things smile what else make
people feel welcome what else project be
nice the best thing listen the best and
most important thing they said to be a
good tour guide is never lose your tour
group you are a bad tour guide if you
lose your tour group and here on campus
they were afraid of people get lost they
might get hurt
the same thing is true in your
communication never lose your audience
because once you lose them it's very
hard to get them back they go to their
phones they go to their friends they go
to sleep we need to keep them with us
setting expectations helps would you
join me on my tour if I showed up and I
said hi I'm Matt let's go a couple of
you adventurous folks would come but the
rest of you you'd be like no way where
are we going why are we going there do I
have the right shoes on
that's why tour guides always set
expectations that structure helps
prepare you so you can be present and
enjoy the tour structuring your
communication does the same thing but
structure also helps with memory for you
and for your audience it provides a map
and you can't be lost if you have a map
so allow me to share with you three of
my favorite structures that once you
have your goal you place your content
into
the first structure is a comparison
contrast conclusion structure you miss
things in common you list things that
are different and then you identify your
particular conclusion another structure
that works very well is the problem
solution benefit structure you start by
talking about what the problem is you
then talk about how you solve it and
ultimately you end with the benefits to
the person listening now sometimes the
problem isn't really a problem it's
really an opportunity so this could
become the opportunity solution benefit
structure as well now finally my most
favorite structure and I'm the kind of
guy that has a favorite structure is the
what so what now what structure in this
structure you start by defining what it
is you're talking about a product or
process an idea you then talk about why
it's important to the people you're
talking to that's the so what
and then the now what are the next steps
what can somebody do with that
information
I like this structure so much because it
not only helps with presenting but it's
a great way to set up a meeting agenda
it's a good way to structure an email
you can even give feedback and answer
questions in this structure I encourage
each and every one of you to try putting
your communication into the structure
now I'm smiling and I'm gonna take a
timeout this is a meta moment for us I
just used what so what now what to
explain what so what now what I told you
what it was why it was important and how
you can use it take these structures or
any structure you find beneficial and
leverage it to make your communication
memorable for you and your audience we
start with a goal and then we put it in
a structure alright enough of me talking
we're gonna put this all together I'm
gonna ask you to find a partner in one
moment and I'm going to ask you to do
something with one of these structures
so to begin how many of you remember
what this device is up here it's a
slinky a children's toy
whose sole purpose I think is to walk
downstairs except in my house and never
worked you are going to sell a slinky to
your partner and then your partner will
sell the very same slinky back to you
using the problem solution benefit
structure identify a problem explain the
solution and explain the benefit now one
caveat this cannot be a children's toy
you have to make it up to be something
else
I never asked my students to do
something I'm not willing to do so allow
me to demonstrate have you all heard of
a terrible plight affecting the African
savannah day after day week after week
elephants are dying why you ask because
their trunks are getting cold allow me
to introduce you to an expandable
elephant trunk warmer with these cheap
very effective supplies and tools you
can reduce the deaths of elephants on
the African savannah each of us must do
our part problem solution benefit here's
what you're going to do you're going to
find a partner for some of you it's just
turn to the person next of you a few of
you might need to move around the room
you have one minute each to sell your
device to your partner ready begin
so I'm very curious I'm very curious
what did this device become for some of
you raise your hand I'll calling you
what was this a cup holder what was it
back there
oh it's a it's a cozy for electric cords
yes sir please an egg timer oh the egg
sort of rolls down yes please a
politically correct way to trap Gophers
yes sir oh it's an exercise tool what in
the back a bagel slicer multiple bagel
slicer excellent I don't know what you
and your partner came up with but in
looking out at you you were having a lot
of fun the the pantomiming was was
fantastic let me ask you this though in
all seriousness was the structure
helpful in you're creating your pitch I
see several of you nodding your heads in
what ways did the structure help you
what did it do for you it helps you
focus on the problem what else does it
do for you it helps you remember where
to go from one to the next what else the
sequence it helps you finish in a lot of
the teaching and coaching I do people
tell me Matt I don't have a problem
communicating I have a problem stopping
communicating so the structure actually
gives you a place to finish after I say
the benefits I'm done it also helps you
move from one place to the next it has
built-in transitions so the flow is
easier so structure helps with memory
but it has a lot of other added benefits
so once we've taken care of our personal
hygiene and we then think about our goal
in our structure the next thing we have
to do to help with our own memory is
practice so I'd like to give you some
advice and guidance on practicing first
when you practice actually stand and
speak if you're in a meeting or you're
preparing for a presentation stand up
and practice I know how most people
practice we open up our slide deck that
we've created we sit and we look at each
slide and we think to ourselves mmm
that's what I'll say mm-hmm that's what
I'll say I don't know about you but in
my mind I'm amazingly eloquent
but when I open up my mouth I'm not
always as lucky so it's useful and
practical to actually stand and speak
and standing helps you focus when I
teach my class here on effective virtual
communication that's where you're doing
webinar or videoconference I encourage
all of my students to stand adjust the
camera and stand it helps you focus it
allows you to use your voice fully and
completely it is a very useful tool
beyond standing to practice we need to
make sure we warm up most speakers
especially those who are nervous go
inside themselves and they think and
they think and they worry and we don't
warm up our voice so our first
utterances aren't necessarily our
strongest I believe warming up is
critical so I'm going to ask you to help
me do the world's quickest and easiest
vocal warmup we are simply going to say
two words a few times each and those two
words are tea cup followed by hiccup so
I'm going to ask you to say each word
three times in a pair so it's going to
be tea cup hiccup tea cup hiccup tea cup
hiccup and we're all going to say it out
loud and I want you to notice where in
your mouth
those two words get produced with me
ready begin tea cup hiccup tea cup
hiccup tea cup hiccup we have a couple
extra credit yes yes yes I know we're
here at Stanford Business School
everybody does the extra when you say
tea cup where in your mouth does that
come from
front top when you say hiccup where does
that come from back lower you've warmed
up your whole voice very simple now I'm
not saying you get up in front of your
very important meeting and say one
moment please DK pick up do you come
here you do this before you enter the
room I like to go around and talk to
people in my audiences in my meetings I
like to make sure I get there early and
talk to people as they come in that's my
way of warming up make sure you're
warmed up for those of you who do
athletics or who exercise you know
warming up is important the same is true
with your communication so we practice
standing up we warm up our voice now
when we practice there's some really
good research
learning theory and cognitive
neuroscience that tells us chunking your
information is very useful take pieces
of it and practice each piece separately
and then assemble it in different ways
so if you're giving a big presentation
perhaps you practice the beginning then
the middle then the end and then the
next time you do the middle the end the
beginning that form of chunking helps
you to remember each part and it helps
you avoid being in a particular pattern
memorization actually works against you
when you are in a high-stress situation
because if you deviate from the script
you're lost so if you are very familiar
with what you're talking about and
practicing in a chunked manner helps you
do that it also helps you give attention
to the end most people because we're so
nervous about how we're going to start
practice the beginning a lot more than
the rest so we figure oh by the time I
get to the end I'll know how to finish
do you know the most common way meetings
and presentations end in the corporate
world I guess we're out of time and
somebody needs the room Thanks that is
not the most effective way to end a
presentation so you must practice each
part in each part individually very
helpful now research done not very far
from here in the psychology department
several decades ago on the Stanford
campus they did a tremendous amount of
work on how where you actually learn
something influences and impacts how you
recall it so if you practice in a
situation that is similar to the
situation in which you will communicate
you are more likely to remember the
information so any of you who are
parents who have instructed your
children when they're studying for a
test or a quiz to study in a quiet place
you're actually doing them a service
you're helping them my children like to
study with lots of noise and devices yet
when they take their exams or have to
write their essays it's in silence
that's actually causing a problem in
terms of their memory so if possible go
into the venue that you'll be presenting
in practice in there that will help you
so there's some very specific things we
can do to help prepare but what happens
if we go blank what happens if we forget
this is the number one fear people
report to me so let me give you some
advice on how to handle blanking out
first don't acknowledge it oh man I just
forgot instead leverage two techniques
I'd like to suggest first repeat what
you just said and see if that gets you
back on track when you lose your keys
how do you find them you retrace your
steps do the same in your presentations
for some reason when we're presenting or
running meetings and we blank out all we
do is think about all the things we need
to do or say in the future I only have
ten more minutes left this is really
important I you have to get the funding
I have to get this good that's all
future thinking you would never do that
if you lost your keys if you lose your
keys you don't stand there say I have to
get to the store I have to pick up day
we don't talk about the future we say
wait I put those keys we go back repeat
what you just said most of us can
remember what we said even if we can't
remember what we intend to say and
simply by repeating yourself it often
will get you back on track now if that
doesn't work let me give you a second
tool and I'm gonna let you in on a
little secret when I teach and I have
some former students here so you're
gonna hear something you heard when you
were a student of mine have a back
pocket question at the ready so if you
forget simply pause and ask your
audience a question thereby giving
yourself time to collect your thoughts
check your notes get back on track
here's what I do in my lectures when I
can't remember what I need to say next
I'll simply pause and say this is a good
place for us to take a pause and I'd
like for you to reflect on something
that we've just discussed and how it
applies to you and your life and you
know what my students do they pause and
reflect on how their life has changed
based on this information and what am i
doing I mean what's next where do I go I
check my notes now if I'm really lost
I'll say turn to your partner next
and tell them the impact that has and my
students think wow Matt really cares and
I do but I'm also finding my place I
want each of you to think about for the
types of communication you do what are
some questions you could ask midway
through or perhaps towards the end or
even at the beginning that would engage
your audience in reflection and distract
them from paying attention to the fact
that you don't know where you are so you
can find out there are lots of types of
questions that you can ask have them at
the ready simply by knowing that you can
repeat yourself go back to go forward or
that you have a back pocket question
makes most people feel more comfortable
and confident when they present which
therefore makes them more able to get
through their presentation and less
likely to forget what they want to say
so the next time you fear blanking out
know you have tools to get you through
it so we've talked about what we can do
to help ourselves remember we've talked
about hygiene that's what we eat we
exercise we sleep we leverage technology
we've talked about how we prepare by
having a goal know feel do and then
creating a structure and then we've
talked about ways to practice we stand
up we chunk information we practice in
the real environment I'd like now to
flip the coin and I'd like to talk about
what we can do to help our audience
remember and this involves three things
- it involves using variation it
involves making sure our content is
relevant and finally how can we leverage
emotion to make ideas stick so let's
start we're gonna talk about variation
and we're going to talk about variety in
several ways first we're going to talk
about variation in your voice
evolution has designed humans to pay
attention to variety to novelty if
something stays the same we habituate if
I were to have talked like this for my
entire lecture you would no longer be
paying attention
and likely be asleep variety is what
keeps us focused so you must put
variation in your voice how do you do
that well record yourself and listen do
you have variation if you notice that
you don't have variety use emotive words
when we invoke emotive words we tend to
reflect their meaning so I might say
this is a really big challenge I
wouldn't say this is a really big
challenge the words really and big
invite that kind of vocal emphasis when
you are practicing make sure that you
extend and exaggerate the way you would
normally say something when we get
nervous we tense up and our vocal cords
are muscles and they tense up too so if
my normal vocal range is here and I get
nervous it becomes here so when I
practice I purposely practice in an
exaggerated way knowing that when I get
nervous
it will come back to my normal range be
mindful of your voice and the variation
in it we must also use variation well
before we get to the next point we also
have to practice I would like all of you
to notice this word up here what is the
word oh we're going to say Oh in a
variety of ways to make sure that we
have variation on our voice in a moment
I'm gonna ask you to say oh is if a
heavy object dropped on your foot you
might say a naughty word after you say
the word oh but I want us all to
practice okay on the count of three
something heavy dropped on your foot I
want you to say Oh ready one two three
oh that was great now you just saw
something so adorable and cute ready one
two three now you've just made a
terrible mistake and you're really sorry
how would you say Oh ready one two three
look what you just did you were able to
take a very simple word and you were
able to convey different meaning by
varying your voice imagine what you
could do in complex sentences and in an
entire presentation or meeting
variety in your voice is what makes it
engaging we also need to think about
variety and the evidence and support
that we use when we communicate there
are lots of things we can do to
encourage people to believe what we're
saying to motivate them to change to
educate them one type of evidence we can
use is data we use lots and lots of data
in our lives when you use data make sure
you provide context so that people
understand what it means but data is but
one type of evidence you could use
another type of evidence has to do with
testimonies third-party voices other
people advocating or supporting what it
is you say and then finally there's
stories examples use cases these to add
value here's the key you must use
variety among these types most of us
communicate using the type that we are
most comfortable with what we like if
I'm a data person when I communicate I
use a lot of data if I'm a storyteller I
tell lots of stories the problem is my
audience isn't all like me so I have to
cast a wide net I have to use variety in
the support I use maybe I give a
testimony and give some data maybe I put
both the testimony and the data in a
story this helps my audience understand
and remember my points use variety to
help you support your points we also
have to think about variety in terms of
the images and visuals we use you'll
notice that many of my visuals are
referring to children's play or toys and
they vary the idea is to keep the
audience engaged if all you show people
is bullet point after bullet point after
bullet point they will habituate
remember bullet skill don't kill your
audience with bullet points use images
now variation is important but so too is
relevance you must make sure that your
content is meaningful and relevant to
your audience that means we have to do
some reconnaissance and reflection about
who's in the
who's listening to my communication
who's reading my messages and we must
tailor our messages to their needs while
some of you will get upset to hear me
say this you need to change and adapt
your communication audience by audience
time by time does that mean more work
for you yes but does it mean that the
impact and the relevance your message
will have will be greater yes and that's
why we do it so we need to tailor our
audience our messages for our audience
in several factors one we have to first
think about their knowledge what do they
know about what we're speaking on we
don't want to come in too high level we
don't want to get too deep we need to
meet our audience where they're at so
you have to think about that you have to
do some reflection you have to ask
people who are in the audience talk to
people who have spoken to this audience
before and ask what's their knowledge
level you must also think about their
expectations what is it they expect from
you and then choose to either conform to
those expectations or perhaps deviate
from them and then finally you need to
understand what are your audience's
attitudes are they in favor of what
you're suggesting
are they agnostic or perhaps hesitant or
resistant and with this information we
can craft our messages and hone them to
be more relevant and memorable I want to
give you an example let's say you are
presenting to an audience that you know
is a bit hesitant or resistant to what
you're advocating for that is valuable
information I might change the way I
structure a message based on it so you
know that problem/solution benefit
structure we talked about if I have a
hesitant or resistant audience it might
be in my best interest to move the
benefits to be the first part start by
talking about the benefits imagine what
it would be like if we could or what if
it was possible to get your audience to
agree to that imagined future and that
reduces their resistance you then say
what's in the way is this particular
problem and here's how we solve it now I
certainly can't guarantee that all
resistance and hesitation will disappear
but I can suggest that by starting with
the benefits you put yourself in a
better position so understanding your
audience their knowledge their
expectations their attitudes can
influence and should influence the way
you communicate so that your audience
will receive your message better and
remember it longer it's not enough just
to tailor our message we also have to
make it engaging and I'd like to suggest
some ways that we can get physical
engagement as well as mental engagement
physical the engagement is to have your
audience do something you could pose a
question rhetorical or a polling
question you can show a video provide a
schematic if you're in the virtual world
have them go to an external website have
them type something into the chat get
your audience involved by having them do
something they are more likely to engage
with the content which we know increases
the likelihood of their remembering but
physical engagement is not enough you
also need mental engagement and there
are lots of ways to do that I already
alluded to one use the word imagine or
what if or picture this we know from
research done two doors down that this
engages areas of the brain associated
with attention and retention so if I can
ask you to imagine or picture this in
your mind you're actually seeing it
which will help you remember it
similarly use analogies analogies
connect what people know to what they
don't know this also makes it stick I
talked about structuring a presentation
is like giving a tour that's an analogy
by engaging our audience physically and
mentally they are much more likely to
remember what we're saying and have a
good time while you're communicating
with them finally we must leverage
emotion we have known for millennia that
emotion is powerful and engages people
and helps them remember so we need to
find ways to leverage emotion in what we
say part of that is how we say it bring
emotion to your messages you
it's congruent and appropriate show that
you have passion show that you have
interest a wonderful technique that
comes from the world of theater and
acting if you are trying to convey
something that you're very that you want
to be exciting for your audience think
about a time you were excited right
before you deliver that message by
getting yourself into that physical
emotion you will deliver it more likely
in that way now some of you are thinking
I get it emotions important but I talk
about things that don't have a lot of
emotion I talk about technology or
science there's not a lot of emotion
there and you might be right but the
consequences in implications and results
of that science and technology has
potential emotion if you're saving trees
saving time saving lives there's emotion
you can tap into take the time to find a
way to bring emotion into your
communication it will help the audience
feel something and remember so we've
talked about several factors that help
make your communication more memorable
we talked about hygiene that's that
preparation we talked about structure
and practice we then talked about what
you can do to help your audience in
terms of variation in relevance and
emotion these are the levers that you
have to pull to make your communication
much more memorable now I want to see
how memorable what we just did together
is for you so I'm gonna ask you to think
about one thing of value that you
learned today in our time together and I
want you to turn to a different partner
somebody perhaps who you didn't work
with last time and I want you to explain
that thing of value using the what so
what now what structure so you're going
to tell your partner what the idea or
tool or tactic is you're going to tell
them why you think that is important and
you're going to then tell them how you
will use it and then your partner will
do the same for you I want to know what
you're carrying out of here that will
help your can
be more memorable so find another
partner pick one thing of value share
that value in the what so what now what
we often don't spend time reflecting on
how we communicate we are so fixated on
just getting it done and moving on that
we don't take time the only way to get
better at your communication is through
three things repetition reflection and
feedback you need to give yourself the
reps you need to give yourself
opportunities to communicate and try new
ways try new structures try varying your
voice try new ways of practice second
you must reflect and think about what
worked and what didn't work
what's that definition of insanity doing
the same thing over and over again
expecting different results we do that
all the time in our communication we
need to think about what worked and what
didn't I challenge all of you who lead
teams and other people at the end of
your meetings or presentations take 30
seconds in debrief what worked and what
didn't work in terms of the
communication not the content but how we
actually communicate it that sends a
very powerful message to your team's the
communication matters and then finally
we need feedback find trusted others
friends family co-workers who can give
you honest feedback use digital
recording as a tool to give yourself
feedback that's how we get better there
are also tools and resources available
to you and I encourage you to take
advantage of them here you see a website
that I curate called no freaking
speaking and this is a website that has
lots of free content from me and from
others you could take advantage of
Stanford continuing studies is a hidden
gem that this campus provides if you
live in the local community look at the
classes they offer there are a
tremendous number of business and
communication classes they also have
many virtual offerings for those of you
visiting us from far away you can take
webinar based classes from continuing
studies and then finally Toastmasters an
international organization designed to
help people feel more comfortable and
confident when they communicate take
time to find avenues
to learn and practice these skills it is
my hope that you are leaving here today
with some specific tactics and
techniques you can use to help you be
more memorable and your messages to be
more memorable when you communicate
before I take your questions and I
invite those questions I have two
questions for you did you learn
something today that you think can help
you in your communication Thanks did you
have a little bit of fun then I have
done my job now I would like to hear
what questions you have of me there's
some microphones in the back people will
get them to you they're coming we'll
have here and then I've said over there
yes sir thank you very much Matt that
was terrific um who is the greatest
speaker in your mind that's ever lived
that is an incredibly hard question oh
just what first comes to your mom right
are you gonna ask me a question because
you were quite blunt no no no I'm not I
have been so moved in the last year by
the teenagers who suffered that great
tragedy in Florida the shooting which
was just absolutely horrific those young
people are among some of the most
eloquent speakers I have heard and
they're not coached they're not trained
and in fact they have actively not
sought that out they've rejected those
who want to help so when I look at
people who have had an impact people
whose messages are memorable people who
deploy some of the techniques we've
talked about I look to those teens in to
me that is so moving
thank you for that question yeah please
over here I was gonna you you mentioned
about talking to an audience that's
hostile but what about an audience that
just doesn't relate to you at all
sometimes I have talked to a group of
students of color and trying to figure
out exactly how to say something that
they're they open their minds to here
and the second question that may be
related is what's the role of humor
right so let me take the second question
first humor is a wonderful way to engage
your audience if you're funny
having a shared laugh is a great way to
bring people together
it engages them the problem is humor is
tricky it's not always funny it's
culturally sensitive you have to be
careful here are my two rules for humor
focus group your jokes if you intend to
use some humor talk to people who are
like people who will be in the audience
and ask them is this funny and most
importantly listen to what they tell you
second use humor about yourself
self-deprecating humor is the safest
even though it might be tempting to talk
about politics or geo issues stay
focused on yourself it's much safer now
how do you relate to an audience that
can be hard a lot of it has to do with
the work you do up front try to
understand what motivates them what are
the issues who are the speakers they
listen to are looking for what what
helps connect and then engage in
dialogue so it's not always about you
talking get them to speak so some of the
best ways to engage an audience that you
feel is going to be disconnected from
you is to ask questions have them talk
to each other become a facilitator
rather than a presenter or teacher and
that's a way to build camaraderie build
trust and to break down some of those
barriers microphones over here yes thank
you those thoughts are applicable to
different cultures I mean that
stretchered is applicable for almost I
will I believe that much of what we've
talked about today is very relevant
cross culturally clearly there are some
things you have to think about in terms
of expectations norms etc to factor into
your communication but I do believe
having a clear goal having a structure
will help figuring out how to engage
your audience will help now that
engagement might differ by culture but
having engagement is critical so yes I
believe at the highest level everything
we've talked about today
spans culture how that gets deployed and
what that looks like we'll have to take
the culture in context into account for
whereas we've got some questions here
and a microphone is coming so great for
presentations yes but often times we are
at our age coaching people so how do you
take that into a two minute synopsis of
how you can use your skills because I've
seen conversations kind of explode I
can't even control it right yeah so just
whatever thoughts you have so I believe
with practice you can get very effective
at quickly coming up with a goal for the
interaction you're about to have and
then use a structure in coaching
situations where you're giving feedback
I think the what's so what now what
structure is wonderful what becomes the
issue or the behavior that you want to
address so what is why it is important
in the now what is the guidance that you
believe the person should undertake so
having that structure can keep it tight
keep it focused and make it memorable
but it takes practice to be comfortable
doing that in a spontaneous way so you
have to practice doing that type of
feedback several times before it becomes
natural but I do believe coming up with
a goal and structuring it can be very
very helpful for feedback as well as
answering questions yes please yeah the
most important takeaway for me is that
before communication preparation is so
important but preparation each time and
usually there's not enough time and he
also suggests us to have a good sleep
and you know so how can we you know
trade off between I wish and the secret
to how we could all get more time in our
lives what I suggest is the more you
practice this the more efficient you
become at it so you can do things more
quickly it also has to do with
prioritization many of us think well I'm
not going to sleep tonight because I'm
gonna drill and drill this big
presentation I have to give in fact the
research suggests getting a good night's
sleep is far better for you than
repetitive practice well tired so part
of it is is prioritizing based on what
you know it will be helpful and then the
other part is just becoming more
efficient at it the more effective and
efficient you are
that the quicker you can do it but it is
a trade-off you have to have that
initial investment I have a very simple
heuristic I use if I have a big
presentation coming up or meeting when
whatever that date is I take the time
between today and that date and I cut it
in half and that first half is
preparation and that second half is
practice most of us sacrifice the
practice piece we're working on our
content up until the last minute because
we think because I've worked on it I'm
gonna be able to deliver it well and
every one of you who has ever done that
knows that's not true so I I just use
that simple heuristic and after you do
that for a while it becomes easier
becomes easier yes please I have a
comment and a question for okay the
first one is it when I was in the Army I
learned the army way of communicating
which is tell them what you're gonna
tell them tell them and tell them what
you told them and you followed that
almost to the liver well thank you the
question yes do you ever use the
Gettysburg Address as an example of
persuasive communication so I use the
Gettysburg Address in my classes in a
different way there is and I'm I'm not
remembering who did this but somebody
took the Gettysburg Address and created
a PowerPoint for it the whole speech
there seven slides and I use it to prove
a point that message is important slides
are less important there's a bar chart
for score right and I mean it's very
funny but it proves a point and you can
you can all go search go search
Gettysburg Address as a PowerPoint and
you will see the seven slides so I use
it but I use it not as a persuasive tool
though it is a very effective tool I use
it to prove the point that that we need
to have our story and message first and
then create slides if we rely too
heavily on slides we we lose a lot and
that that makes that point very very
well other questions yes I I have a
class that I have to give in Galway
Ireland of Executive MBA students yes
and they're a wonderful wonderful group
but you know what the Irish are like
and occasionally I'm very friendly yes
they are that they're fantastic
especially after the class is over in my
club haha that's right
but occasionally I have a student or two
that will start looking at their mobile
phone during my my piece which I suppose
is partly a criticism of me but the
others don't so it isn't a total
criticism how do you handle individuals
or do you just ignore them who appear to
be distracted by something else so I
always make the assumption that when
people are doing something distracting
like looking at their phone that there
is a important reason that they're doing
so so I start from a place of compassion
rather than it would just hurt my ego
too much to be thinking that I'm boring
right but what I try to do is I try to
engage non-verbally if you're standing
up you can move closer to the people who
are distracted and and we've all learned
that as the voice gets louder we should
pay attention try to bring them in
asking questions works well what I have
learned in the digital age that I teach
in and all my students that haven't you
know not just one but multiple devices
sometimes you can actually enlist the
devices and what you do so you can ask
people go search on this or there are
tools that allow you to take polls
through texting so people text a certain
number and that's a poll and you can
actually show the data live so rather
than fight the technology see if there
ways that you can leverage it to help
you accomplish your goal and that that
will make you feel better and it'll
actually lead to some very interesting
interactions thank you yes please oh you
don't have a mic mic is coming kind of
the company's culture when you're giving
for example uh the founder of Trader
Joe's Joe Colome said that in all his
messaging he always wanted to have fun
with the customer as you give these
presentations do you take into account
kind of what drives the company and have
that in your messaging absolutely so I
try to practice what I preach so when I
go in and do some consulting with
companies all around the world I spend
time trying to understand the culture
and the values and I watch some of the
senior leaders to see what they do and
then I infuse that in the advice that I
give them and that can be really
important it could also get me in
trouble I went to one
start up not too far from here and the
executive team had a tradition of
cursing in their presentations and so so
we had some interesting examples in the
workshop I led but understanding what
they do and how they do it is very
important for sure yes please a
microphone is coming your way thank you
it was great I used my mobile for
sharing the slides to the group oh thank
you good reason thank you I I have to
tell you this taking pictures of slides
is new and I never know where to stand I
always feel like I'm photobombing my
materials and so so I'm getting used to
it but yes Nicholas you're going to love
your pictures excellent my you look
great yes thank you look great and I'm
blanking ask me a question no I know if
I'm blanking on desking good question so
I think it was about what do you do is
interrupt so sometimes you're presenting
and you get asked questions yeah how do
you handle Samia is a choker yes and a
perfect interrupter so what do you do
what do you do when something interrupts
your flow so if you can ignore it ignore
it if it's you know if it's somebody's
cellphone going off or something of that
nature ignore it if it's somebody
interrupting with a question or some
kind of comment what I recommend you do
is you use paraphrasing to take
something from what they're saying and
then redirect so if somebody's saying
but what about this what about this you
could say ah that's an important point
I'm really interested in and notice what
I've just done I acknowledged and then I
move away
I've signaled I'm done with you
non-verbally here's the challenge when
you are in a situation where you were
under under some kind of interrupts or
somebody's challenging you you have to
balance being appropriate versus being
rude to the individual but also to the
rest of the group if somebody is being
distracting and interrupting and
disrupting the rest of the room is
feeling that tension and very rarely
will the rest of the room help you
they're looking for you to deal with it
and if you don't
then your credibility is affected so you
have to to understand that you need to
manage that and manage it as politely as
you can and I firmly believe that
paraphrasing taking something of value
and then redirecting is the way to
handle that I'm going to take one more
question to stay on time but I will stay
afterwards and ask individual questions
is there a final question right over
here thank you
thank you my question is how do you
change track in a conversation or rather
engaging conversation especially when
you're conversing statements is like one
question after another but meanwhile
you're well aware the conversation is
just going downward against you're going
to want it too right so how do you
regard the conversation and again I
don't mean to sound repetitive but I
really think paraphrasing is a very
polite tool for doing that so
acknowledge that you hear what the
person is saying oh I understand what
you're saying or I hear where that's
going I'm curious to know how so use it
as a bridge so the paraphrase
acknowledges and then bridge to the
direction that you wish to go I believe
paraphrasing when paired with structure
and having a goal are the three
essential ingredients to effective
communication those are the bottom line
tools if you can create goals structure
your messages and know how to paraphrase
the content it can really help
I would like simply to conclude by
saying thank you each of us has
important ideas and stories and messages
to convey we must take the time to make
sure that they are memorable for us so
we can communicate them clearly and
memorable for our audience so they can
take them with them with that I hope you
are taking away some memorable ideas to
help you be a more effective
communicator thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]